you were part of a webinar titled
advancing Road Safety the state of
alcohol intoxication research
so for people who don't know every year
1.3 million people around the world die
in Road crashes
and more than 20 percent of these
fatalities are estimated to be alcohol
related a lot of them are also
distraction related so can AI help with
the alcohol thing
I think the answer is yes there are
signals and we know that as humans like
we can tell in a person
you know is that different phases of
being drunk
um right yeah and I think you can use
technology to do the same and again I
think the ultimate solution is going to
be a combination of different sensors
how hard is the problem from the vision
perspective
untrivial
part is getting the data right it's like
getting enough data examples so we for
This research project we partnered with
the transportation authorities of Sweden
and we literally had a race track with a
safety driver and and we basically
progressively got people drunk nice so
but but you know
uh that's that's a very expensive data
set to to to collect and you want to
collect it globally and in multiple
conditions and yeah the the ethics of
collecting a data set where people are
drunk is tricky yeah yeah definitely
which is funny because I mean let's put
Drunk Driving aside the number of drunk
people in the world every day is very
large it'd be nice to have a large data
set of drunk people getting
progressively drunk in fact you could
build an app where people can donate
their data because it's hilarious
right actually yeah but but the
liability liability the ethics the how
do you get it right It's Tricky it's
really really tricky because like
drinking is one of those things that's
funny and hilarious and what loves it's
social the the so on and so forth but
it's also the thing that uh hurts a lot
of people like a lot of people like
alcohol is one of those things it's
legal but it it it it it's really
damaging to a lot of lives it destroys
lives and not just in the driving
context
um I should mention people should listen
to Andrew huberman who recently talked
about
um alcohol he has an amazing podcast
Andrew humor is a neuroscientists from
Stanford a good friend of mine oh cool
and he he's like a human encyclopedia
about all health related wisdom so if
there's a podcast you you would love it
I would love that no no no no no no oh
you don't know Andrew huberman okay
listen you listen to to Andrew he's
called huberman Lab podcast this is your
assignment just listen to one okay I
guarantee you this will be a thing where
you say Lex
this is the greatest human I've ever
discovered so oh my God because I've
really have kind of health and wellness
and I'm learning lots and I'm trying to
like build these
I guess Atomic habits around just being
healthy
um so I yeah I'm definitely gonna do
this I'm gonna his whole thing this is
this is this is this is great uh he's a
legit scientist like um really well
published but in his podcast
what he does he's not he's not talking
about his own work he's like a human
Encyclopedia of papers and so he his
whole thing is he takes the topic and in
a very fast you mentioned Atomic Habits
Like very clear way summarizes the
research
in a way that leads to Protocols of what
you should do he's really big on like I
love that not like this is what the
science says but like this is literally
what you should be doing according to
the side so like he's really big and
there's a lot of recommendations he does
uh which several of them I definitely
don't do like
get sunlight
um as soon as possible from waking up
and like for prolonged periods okay
that's a really big one and he's there's
a lot of science behind that one there's
there's a bunch of stuff
you're gonna and you're gonna be like
Lex this is uh this is my new favorite
person I guarantee it
and if you guys somehow don't know
Andrew huberman and you care about your
well-being
um you know you should definitely listen
to him
I love you Andrew anyway so uh what were
we talking about oh alcohol and
detecting alcohol so this is a problem
you care about and you're trying to
solve and actually like broadening it
um I
I believe that the car is going to be a
Wellness Center like because again
imagine if you have a variety of sensors
inside the vehicle
Tracking not just your emotional state
or level of distraction and drowsiness
and drowsiness
level of distraction challenge
drowsiness and intoxication but also
maybe even things like
um
your physical you know your heart rate
and your heart rate variability and your
breathing rate
um
and it can start like optimizing yeah it
can optimize the ride based on what your
goals are so I think we're going to
start to see more of that I'm I'm
excited about that